[Musique]
après trois mois de fermeture la
passerelle des trois pays à huningue a
retrouvé son rôle de trait d'union
depuis le 15 juin les frontières franco
allemande est franco suisses sont de
nouveau ouvertes à la libre circulation
et les habitants on peut retrouver leurs
habitudes les élus les deux rives du
rhin se sont également rencontrés un
symbole important dans ce retour imposer
des frontières avait été un moment
difficile
on avait oublié qu'il y avait des
frontières et tout d'un coup il ya trois
mois et bien les frontières entre la
suisse et la france entre l'allemagne et
la france se sont fermées et c'est là
qu'on s'est rendu compte et bien que nos
voisins avec lesquels nous travaillons
au quotidien et bien comptait beaucoup
pour nous que ce sont des parterres mais
que ce sont aussi avant tout des amis
est ce que je retiens de cette crise et
de la fermeture des frontières c'est que
malgré la fermeture des frontières et
bien la coopération transfrontalière et
la solidarité transfrontalière à
fonctionner puisque grâce à l'aide de
nos amis allemands et de nos amis
suisses et bien des vies de patients
alsaciens ont été sauvés je suis très
heureuse
ce matin il y aussi je dois dire ténue
hirvonen dans ce petit bout d'alsace on
vit l'europe au quotidien suisse
français et allemands vivent et
travaillent chez les uns et chez les
autres
sans s'embarrasser des rimes et
administrative des états c'était
tellement tellement pas dans nos
habitudes que on avait des amis suisses
allemands et moi alsaciens qui prenait
la voiture pour aller avec une mince
c'est fermé donc donc très très
difficile comme je l'aï dit c'est
tellement habituel
c'est un réflexe d'aller les uns chez
les autres mais pour nous en fait envie
de vie le dry land ce ce concept qui
peut apparaître vu de loin juste comme
ça comme juste des démos pour nous
dresse les trois pays c'est une réalité
sont présents des îles françaises
suisses et allemands
si les nationalités et les institutions
qu'ils représentent sont différentes
tous s'accordent à dire qu'à l'avenir il
faudra tout faire pour éviter une
nouvelle fermeture de la frontière au
conseil départemental brigitte klinkert
souhaite renforcer les liens qui
unissent déjà alsacien badoit et bâlois
il n'y a pas de lieu plus symbolique je
crois que la passerelle des trois pays
ici à j'aime pas le mot frontières mais
à la limite entre la france l'allemagne
et la suisse c'est un petit bout
d'europe qui en fait pour moi un
véritable modèle de fonctionnement de
l'europe et vous et vous savez dans
moins de six mois va d'être la
collectivité européenne d'alsace le
coeur du projet de la collectivité en
termes d'alsace c'est l'europe et nous
travaillons actuellement à la mise en
place d'un schéma de coopération
transfrontalière et bien dans lequel un
volet sanitaire et mig et médico social
aura toute sa place parce que demain on
doit plus vivre ce que nous avons connu
pendant cette crise
[Applaudissements]
ce jour de réouverture des frontières
c'est aussi l'occasion pour l'exécutif
départemental et remercié les équipes
médicales de l'hôpital universitaire de
fribourg
pendant la crise 140 patients atteints
par le corona virus ont été évacués en
allemagne vers le 20 mars la situation
dans nos hôpitaux étaient très
compliquées
les lits de réanimation étaient saturés
nos patients alsacien partait vers
bordeaux vers marseille vers brest
et c'est là que je me suis dit c'est pas
possible
nous avons des hôpitaux à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de colmar et de
mulhouse et c'est là que j'ai pris
l'initiative de solliciter le land de
bade wurtemberg qui a répondu
positivement et j'ai rencontré des
équipes de médecins deux professionnels
juste extraordinaire de grandes qualités
professionnelles de grandes qualités
humaines et aussi des européens
convaincus liste
l'hôpital de fribourg vu le premier
accueillir un patient alsacien au mois
de mars
les remerciements formulés lors de cette
visite sont allés droit au coeur des
équipes médicales mobilisés pendant
trois mois au chevet des patients
français
je tire mon chapeau à votre résidence
présidente madame kathleen coeur parce
qu'elle a visité aujourd'hui nous les
est une chose pour nous très important
et pour notre collègue pour tous les
codecs très très important et c'est une
motivation très fort pour notre
coopération avec notre ami avec nos amis
et avec nous on va en alsace et rurale
de part et d'autre du rhin la crise
sanitaire aura mis en lumière
l'importance de ces bâtisses et
localement année après année a dit m
soft c'est une amitié qui maintenant a
pu faire ses preuves et c'est cette
amitié vécu dont nous voulons maintenant
tirer nos enseignements également pour
l'avenir et en faire encore plus nommé à
main
cette journée d'aujourd'hui je
l'attendais en 2021 la collectivité
européenne d'alsace verra le jour
officiellement résolument orientée vers
la coopération transfrontalière
l'institution devrait porter des projets
en matière de santé
ça va être l'occasion de développer des
projets communs entre l'alsace et le
bade-würtemberg pour permettre un
système de soins transfrontaliers aussi
au service de nos concitoyens qu'ils
puissent plus facilement se faire
soigner en allemagne voire en suisse est
pareil que les allemands ou les suisses
puissent plus facilement venir se faire
soigner en alsace